welcome to vlog university the only show
on youtube that after you're done
watching the video you have to go do
some homework but i promise you it's fun
homework
right
in the last episode your homework
assignment was to create a video about
your favorite t-shirt and i got a lot of
submissions this is by far the best
submission that i have seen it's a video
by rachel tom who's an extremely
talented musician who wrote a song and
made a music video about her favorite
t-shirt now she cheated a little bit
because there's more than one t-shirt in
this video justine has asked me to do a
simple task
i don't think it's too
much to ask
to pick a t-shirt
second to none
i must admit it's
hard to choose just one
i like my black shirt white shirt loose
your tight shirt my pink shirt red shirt
striped shirt shirt be sure to check out
her channel at rachel tom music for the
rest of that video because it's
absolutely fantastic and now we have a
tucker commentates with a squirrel
t-shirt my favorite shirt i would choose
this one because it's got a square on it
now no t-shirt video would be complete
without a justin bieber t-shirt
you want to know why it's my favorite
shirt because the biebs is on it and i
justine you know what i'm talking about
the beebs
here's a nicely edited video by sofia
cools showing off her weeby jamming
t-shirt here is my favorite t-shirt it's
just green plain white one but this
t-shirt is my favorite cue the drum roll
please
so this is my favorite t-shirt it says
on it we be german i'm pretty sure i
caitlyn knew that she would be included
in this next vlog university episode
because she's wearing a steeler t-shirt
it's actually a jersey but it's okay
it's okay
i love the steelers and this is why it's
my favorite t-shirt it's more like a
jersey
but
not quite
so these next two t-shirts are pretty
awesome the first t-shirt is me dancing
on somebody else's t-shirt
then we have this other t-shirt it's
stereo activated dancing t-shirt shirt
and last we have the next nerd with two
of his favorite t-shirts
back the f drive up
and just got about everything during
here
and yeah that last apple logo light up
t-shirt i may or may not have that same
one
thank you all so much for submitting
your homework assignments for this
episode of vlog university and of course
vlog university itself you are all
amazing and now i'm sure you're just
waiting so patiently for what your
homework assignment is for the next
episode i know a lot of you guys
probably know that i'm super into
playing video games and i'm pretty sure
a lot of you guys are too so your
homework assignment for the next episode
of vlog university is to create a video
game video now this can be you playing
video games or this can be you in a real
life video game or it can be something
entirely different that has to do with
video games it's up to you once you've
completed your homework assignment just
add it as a video response to this video
here now i know i used to give away vlog
university t-shirts and i'm gonna start
giving those away each episode and if
you'd like to win one just leave a
comment below saying why you should win
a vlog university t-shirt like and
favorite this video and come back here
next week to see who won thank you guys
so much for watching be sure to
subscribe so you'll know when i launch a
new video and check out the rest of my
youtube channels here
on youtube i'm just going to give you a
second to think about
what you want to do over here
okay that's long enough bye